Hello, everyone.
And welcome to
lecture 7 of CME 295.
So today, we're going to
focus on practical techniques
to let our LLM interact
with the outside world
with other systems.
Because up until now, our
LLM was purely on its own.
We've trained it.
We've seen how it can reason
on problem math, coding math,
coding problems.
And now, what we want to do is
to use our LLM in the context
of other systems.
So today's class,
we'll focus on RAG,
that you may have heard,
tool calling, and agents.
But before we
start, as usual, I'm
going to recap what
we did last time.
So if you remember, last time,
we focused on reasoning models.
And we saw the differences
between reasoning model
and what we call
the vanilla LLM.
And in particular, up until the
lecture before last lecture,
what we saw was we fed
a prompt to the LLM,
and it gave us
directly a response.
But what we saw last time
was that if we let the LLM
reason before
outputting the response,
then we can gain
some performance
when it comes to reasoning
tasks, such as math and coding.
And so, in particular,
reasoning models, what they do
is they take a prompt as input,
and then what they output
is both a reasoning
chain, which is typically
hidden from the user,
and then a response.
So with that, we
saw how we could
train a model to be more
of a reasoning model.
And in particular, we
saw a core RL algorithm
called GRPO, which stands
for Group Relative Policy
Optimization.
And we saw that
this algorithm had
some differences compared to
the ones that we saw previously.
And in particular,
one notable aspect
is that it does not have--
it does not train
a value function.
So here, this illustration
shows a little bit
how GRPO is trained.
So it takes a query as input.
And then it computes an
advantage for each output
by computing the rewards
for different completions
of a same prompt.
And then computing
a quantity, which
is the advantage, that is
relative to the other rewards
of that group of completions.
And then we saw
that if we applied
GRPO with carefully
chosen rewards, which
is one, rewarding the model for
outputting a reasoning chain,
and then second,
rewarding the model
for producing a good response.
What we saw is that as the
RL training progresses,
we have an improvement of the
model on these reasoning tasks.
And so we saw one of the
tasks being math problems.
So here on the left graph,
you see the evolution
of the performance of the model
on the aim data set, which
is a challenging math problem.
And we saw that, but we
also saw that the model
kept on outputting responses
that were longer and longer.
And in particular,
we saw that even
though towards the end
of the graph above,
that the performance
was plateauing.
We saw that the output
length was still increasing.
So then what we did was go back
to the loss formulation that
is used by GRPO and
realize that there
is a term that makes
the contribution
of a token different, if
it is in a short response
or a long response.
So this is a phenomenon
called length bias.
And we saw some
mitigation strategies
that were explored by
some papers that came out
in the past few months.
So one was DAPO, which had
a normalization factor that
was not dependent on where
the token was located
and which sentence
it was located.
And the other one was this
paper called "GRPO Done Right,"
which actually just removed
the normalization term.
All good on that?
Cool.
So this was last time.
And last time,
what we said right
before starting
the reasoning class
was to enumerate the strengths
and the weaknesses of vanilla
LLMs.
So last lecture was
all about focusing
on how we can improve
the limited reasoning
capabilities of vanilla LLMs.
And in this lecture, what
we will do is two things.
So the first one is see how we
can connect our LLM to the ever
evolving knowledge base,
and, in particular,
see how we can have access
to the latest information.
And then the second
one is how our LLM
can help us perform actions.
And we will see
this with Shervine
with things like tool calling
and agentic workflows.
Cool.
So with that, let's
start with the first one.
And let's start with
this method called RAG,
that you may have heard.
So let's suppose you have a
model that you have trained.
But the problem is that the
pre-training data on which you
have trained your
model is, let's say,
a month ago, let's suppose.
Now, let's suppose you
want to prompt your model
about the winner of
the elections that
happened a couple of weeks ago.
Well, your model will not
be able to respond to you,
or it will output the incorrect
answer because up until now,
our LLM does not have any
link to outside sources.
It only relies on
the knowledge that it
has acquired during training.
So the response
that it will give us
will only be based
on the data that
has been trained up
until the cutoff, which
is a month ago in this example.
And so we have this big
limitation, which is our LLM
only knows about things
that it has been trained on.
And you will see that
all the models out there.
So here, I have an
example with OpenAI GPT-5
So if you look at
their model cards,
they always have these
knowledge cutoff dates
that is written somewhere.
And in the case, for
instance of GPT-5,
the knowledge cutoff date
is September 30, 2024,
which means that if you ask it
in a very naive way, anything
that happened after that,
the base model will not
be able to answer you as is.
Well, you may tell
me why not just
continue training your model on
data that happened after that?
Well, the problem with
that-- actually, there
are several problems with this.
So the first problem is
that it's very tricky
to change the
knowledge of an LLM
without causing regression
on other things.
So this is typically a task that
people, they try to avoid doing.
And the second thing is
it's not very practical,
because you may very well
have use cases that require
you to fine tune this model.
So let's suppose
you have a use case
one, you fine tune
from this model.
And then somehow you want to
update the weights of your model
to inject some knowledge.
Well, you somehow will have to
do that for all the use cases
that you are doing, which
basically adds a lot of overhead
for you and just adds
a lot of maintenance.
So people, they typically prefer
to not do additional training
to inject knowledge.
So one idea can be to
somehow take your prompt
and just add anything that
happens after the cutoff
date as a way for your model
to just know what happened.
Well, the problem with
that naive approach
is that as you know
context length is limited.
And so typically,
models have on the order
of magnitude of hundreds
of thousands of tokens
in context length.
Do you know what
that is roughly--
what it is roughly equal to?
Yes.
So one token is equal
to four characters.
So using this rough
approximation,
hundreds of thousands
of tokens is roughly
like hundreds of pages,
something like a very big book.
It's big, but it's
not enough for us
to go in that very naive route.
So again, going back to GPT-5,
so if you go to the model card,
you have the knowledge cutoff
date, which is September 2024.
You also have the
context window.
And in this case,
it's 400,000 tokens.
So let's suppose actually,
context is not a problem.
It's actually unlimited.
Let's imagine we actually put
everything in the context.
Well, the problem
then is that people
noticed that if you feed a
lot of irrelevant information
to your LLM, the performance of
the LLM will actually degrade.
Meaning, that if for instance,
you ask it about, I guess,
who was the winner of
the last elections?
And then you feed it
a bunch of information
that are not relevant, your
LLM will tend to be confused.
And so people have
run these tests.
That's called the needle in a
haystack test, where the idea is
you give a big prompt to your
LLM, which is your haystack,
and you place a
fact in the prompt.
And you ask your model
what that fact was.
So the idea is for
your LLM to know,
I guess, among that
huge prompt, where
is the relevant information,
which is the needle.
And so when people
have tried doing
this for several
length of prompts
and tried different positions
of where to put the facts,
they have seen that the length
of the prompt and the position
at which you put the
facts are both important.
So here on the slide,
we have a heat map
that was performed for
GPT-4, which was I guess one
or two years ago.
And what the person
did was placed the fact
at different places
in the document.
So this is document
depth, and the x-axis
is the length of your prompt.
And what we saw was
that for prompts that
exceeded a certain
amount of tokens,
the LLM actually had trouble
retrieving the correct piece
of information.
And in particular, it
had trouble doing so
when the fact was somewhere in
the first half of the prompt.
So this just tells us that,
even if, let's say, our context
length was unlimited,
we would still
have a problem by just going
through that naive approach.
So that's another reason.
So now, let's suppose,
context length is unlimited.
Let's suppose the problem that
I mentioned is not a problem.
Well, the other problem
is that you pay.
So in particular, these
calls, these LLM calls,
they are per token.
So the bigger your input
prompt, the more you will pay.
So you have an incentive to not
put too much in your prompt just
from that standpoint.
And so for instance,
again, going back to GPT-5,
order of magnitude is somewhere
around $1 per million token.
So I guess it's
not that expensive,
but it can add up, if you do
that for all your prompts.
So for all these reasons,
I hope I convinced you
that we need a more
clever approach, where
instead of putting all the
new information all at once
in the prompt, what we
do is we only somehow
find the relevant information
and put that in the prompt.
So that is the idea behind RAG.
RAG stands for Retrieval
Augmented Generation.
And the idea here is to augment
the prompt with relevant
information.
And here, I put
relevant in bold.
And this is the, I guess, the
core part of this technique
is how can we get only the
relevant part in the prompt?
So we'll see that in a second.
So just at a very high
level, so you have,
let's say, a question as input.
So in this case, who was
the winner of, let's say,
the local election?
The idea here is
to somehow fetch
the correct or the relevant
piece of information
and then augment that here in
order to output your answer.
So that's the rough idea.
So does this method
make sense so far?
Yeah.
OK.
Cool.
So that is the idea behind RAG.
And now, we're going to
go into more details.
So what I mentioned
is the rough idea.
And here, I just
want to emphasize
on the three main steps of RAG.
So first one is you
have your prompt,
and you somehow want to retrieve
a relevant piece of information
that will help you in
answering your prompt.
So here, the first step is to
retrieve relevant documents.
And so you can think of your
prompt as being one entity.
And then you can have some
other space, which maybe, I
don't know, knowledge base,
where all your documents live.
And so the idea is to somehow
fetch the relevant documents.
So this is the retrieve step.
The second step is
once you have fetched
the relevant information,
you augment your prompt.
So you take that retrieved info.
You just put it in your prompt,
and then ask the question.
So in the local
election example,
it's as if I was saying, who
is the winner of this election?
And then I retrieve the
relevant piece of information.
And now, the prompt becomes, who
is the winner of this election?
And by the way, this election
was held, blah, blah, blah.
And this was the winner.
And this is what we're
feeding to our LLM.
So in other words, we're giving
the answer in the prompt.
And the third step is to
feed that prompt to the LLM
to generate the response.
Yeah?
Exactly.
So the question is, you
may very well somehow
do a bad job at
retrieval stage, so yes.
So this is why the retrieval
stage is so important.
And we're going to focus on
what we can do to make sure
that one part does well.
We'll see how we can
evaluate, I guess,
our setup and different methods.
But when we talk
about RAG, we're
mainly focusing on
making the retrieval
parts as good as it can.
Cool.
And I just want to
emphasize once again
on why it's called RAG.
So you have retrieve,
augment, generate--
RAG.
Cool.
And as you pointed
out, the first step,
which is the retrieval
step is very important,
which is why we'll spend a
little bit of time over there.
So I guess the
first step is for us
to somehow clean the set of
documents that we may need.
So I said, we may want to
look into outside information,
but we need to somehow sort that
order that put that somewhere.
And this whole thing is usually
called a knowledge base.
So in order to form
our knowledge base,
what we do is typically
collect the set of documents
that are or may be useful.
And once we do that, what
we do is we divide them
into, what we call, chunks.
So a chunk is you
can think of it
as a subset of
the document which
has a given maximum
length, which is
are measured in number of
tokens, which is typically
on the order of
hundreds of tokens.
And the idea here is
whenever you hear retrieval,
you should think
about embeddings.
And here, what we do is we
compute embeddings corresponding
to each of these chunks.
Now, when you create
your knowledge base,
there are a few hyperparameters
that you need to tweak.
So the first one, obviously,
is the size of the embedding.
So typically, you would
want a bigger size,
if, let's say, your
documents are maybe
more nuanced, more complex.
But then if you
have a higher size,
maybe it will take more space.
Maybe you'll have more
computation at inference time.
So I guess it's a trade-off.
You don't necessarily want
too big of an embedding size.
So here, typically,
embedding sizes
are on the order of thousands.
So for instance, like
1,500 something like this.
So then you have the chunk size.
Chunk size is how big your
little pieces here are.
So you don't want them to be
too small, because, otherwise,
the text may be out of context.
You don't want it
to be too large,
because maybe the embedding
will not represent,
in a meaningful
way, what is inside.
So again, it's a trade-off.
But typically,
people they choose
chunk size of around 500
tokens, like, on the order
of hundreds of tokens.
And then you also
have a-- oh yeah.
You have a question.
Yeah?
So the question is, do you train
an embedding model for this.
So you have two
choices, either you
can use a pre-trained embedding
model, which people typically
do, or you can train your own.
We will see that in a bit
more detail in a few slides.
So the question is, what is the
purpose of the embedding model?
So we will see this in a second.
But long story short, it
tries to represent chunks,
such that it achieves
your end goal,
which is to fetch
relevant documents.
So we will see a little
bit how they're trained.
But this is the general idea.
Cool.
So that's this.
And then we have a
third hyperparameter,
which is how much
overlap you want
to have in between your chunks.
So here, when you do the
division, in a very naive way,
you have everything be
independent, no overlap
in between.
But typically,
you have some part
that is from the
previous chunk that
is relevant to understand
the current chunk, which
is why we want to have
some overlap, which
is why people, they
typically also have that.
So it's typically in the
low hundreds of tokens.
Cool.
So let's suppose you
have your knowledge base.
Now, the question
is, given a prompt,
how can you retrieve
relevant documents?
And the answer to that is we
typically proceed in two steps.
So I'm not sure
if any of you has
a background in recommendation
systems or search.
Does any?
Yeah.
So the methods we're seeing here
are very similar to that space.
So I guess people in
the LLM community.
They have borrowed ideas and
just leveraged some techniques
that we have over there.
And this is typically, a
setting that will also have
for recommendation problems.
So we have two stages.
So the first stage is typically
called candidate retrieval.
And the goal here
is to go from a set
of many, many, many
chunks, and filter it down
to a much smaller set of
potentially relevant candidates.
So during that stage,
what we're trying to do
is to somehow maximize recall,
just do a rough operation,
so that we get as many
potentially relevant candidates
as possible.
And then we have a second stage,
which is sometimes optional.
But this stage is to really make
sure we have the top documents
being really the relevant ones.
And this one is called ranking.
So the idea here is based on
the list of potentially relevant
documents, to really
rank them in a way
that really the relevant ones
come at the top and so on.
And typically,
during that stage,
we're going to use a
model, a method that's
going to be a bit more compute
intensive because we have
a much smaller set of
candidates to rank compared
to the first one.
So going back to your
question on how do we
want our embeddings to be?
So here, it will really
impact the first stage.
And we will see
that in a second.
But the second stage is
also quite important.
Cool.
So far so good?
Is everyone clear with
the two-stage approach?
Yeah.
Very good question.
So the question is, do we
chunk things in a naive way,
as in we just go with
the number of tokens
regardless of what happens?
So it's a great question.
And the answer is that we
will see some extensions that
will mitigate the problem of
when you chunk it in a way that
does not make sense
in a naive way,
you want to somehow
put that into context.
And we will see a
method that does that.
So in a few slides,
we will see that.
But I think your question
is also a great question,
because depending on the kind
of document that we have,
for instance, if we have,
I don't know, like a JSON
file or a markdown or depending
on the file that you need
to chunk, you also need to be
aware of the structure that
is within those files.
So there is also
some nuance there
that we will not
go into details,
but I just want
to call that out.
But, yeah, great question.
Any other questions?
OK.
Cool.
So now that we're clear on the
two main stages of retrieval,
we're going to focus on
each one of these steps.
So as I mentioned, the first
step is candidate retrieval.
So here, what we want is among
that potentially huge knowledge
base to somehow
filter it down to,
let's say, over 100 potentially
relevant candidates.
So here, what we do is well,
we will leverage the embeddings
that I guess computed during the
knowledge base initialization.
And we will try to fetch
potentially relevant candidates
by doing a semantic
similarity search.
So do you recall how
we compare embeddings?
Yes.
So cosine similarity
is typically
one way one good way
to compare embeddings.
So the idea here is to represent
our query with an embedding.
We already have embeddings
of all our chunks.
So the idea here is to somehow
find the most relevant chunks
by doing this similarity
search and filtering out
the ones that come at the top.
So the idea here is you have
your query, you have your chunk.
both of them, you
find an embedding.
And then you perform a
similarity operation,
which is most of the
time cosine similarity.
And you obtain a
similarity score.
So the idea here is you
just keep top, I don't 100,
and you go with that.
So I just want to
call out that there
is some complexity
in that stage,
because your knowledge base
can potentially be huge.
So what people do
is typically use
what we call approximate
nearest neighbor methods.
So you may have heard of
some libraries that do that.
So typically, this is something
that will be relevant here.
We're not going to
go into details,
but I just want
to call that out.
So here, the idea here is that
when you build your knowledge
base, you somehow
partition the embeddings
in a way that will avoid-- like
make you avoid doing like just
a naive linear search.
So that's the idea.
But you may see some
techniques like ANN techniques,
approximate nearest
neighbor techniques.
And these are typically
happening here.
So another thing that
I want to point out
is the name of the architecture
that we typically use here
that you may also hear.
And for that, we need to
recall that these embeddings,
they're actually obtained by
passing them through a model.
So typically encoder only.
So you may hear the
term BI encoder.
And this one refers
to the fact that we
are passing the query
through an encoder
and then passing the
chunk through an encoder.
So both of them are independent.
And we're comparing
the embeddings.
So this is another question
I wanted to ask you.
But I guess I didn't
get the chance to.
If you remember, I think
lecture two or three,
we had seen the BERT model.
And so typically, you would have
something like a BERT-like model
that you would use to
encode these documents.
So going back to your
question, how do you
compute these embeddings?
So there is a paper that I
highly recommend reading.
Actually, that's
called Sentence BERT.
And so that paper explains--
so it's, first of all,
it's an extension of BERT,
as the name suggests.
And it's an
extension that allows
you to compute an
embedding per, let's say,
sequence for your query,
for your document, that
is tailored to be used for
similarity search purposes.
So the idea here is to
have a loss function that
will incentivize
having a high cosine
similarity for relevant
entities and low cosine
similarity for entities
that are not relevant.
So yeah, so feel free
to check that paper out,
if you know BERT,
which I know right now,
you do, it's quite easy to read.
So highly recommend.
So far so good?
Yeah?
So the question is,
what is the default
way to compute the similarity?
So yes, it's cosine similarity.
But again, you will see in
different implementations
that people can use
other distances.
And I would encourage
you to think about how
they relate to one another.
So you will see, for
instance, the L2 distance.
But then if everything
has a norm of 1,
there's a lot of
simplifications that can happen.
So you may see some
variants, but I
would say they're all more
or less cosine similarities.
Yeah, great question.
Cool.
So we're still at the
candidate retrieval stage.
And what we saw was one
way of retrieving documents
from a similarity--
sorry from a semantic
similarity standpoint.
So by the way, what does
semantic similarity mean?
It means is finding documents
or finding entities that
have the same meaning
or that are relevant,
but in the way that we
compute these embeddings,
we're not enforcing any
kind of keyword match,
like when we retrieve
documents in this way,
it can very well be that the
documents that are matched,
they do not have any word in
common, but they mean the same.
Well, sometimes
you want to ensure
that what you're looking for,
what you're searching for,
is exactly containing the
keywords that is in your prompt.
And in that case, you
would want to have
a second way of doing things.
So you may have
seen BM25 out there.
So BM25 is a relevant score that
is actually a heuristic score.
It is based on some
function of the overlap
between what is in your query
and what is in your document.
And so that one is actually
quite handy for cases, where
you have a query
where you absolutely
want to have documents that
contain keywords of this query.
So here, I have an example that
I actually passed super briefly
for the previous one.
And we will come back to it.
But let's suppose we have
let's say two teddy bears.
One is named Cuddly and the
other one is named Huggy.
So what you want is to
figure out where is Cuddly.
So this is your query.
So if you use BM25,
well, the answers
that you are going to
get are by definition
going to contain some overlap of
words that were in your query.
And so here, you
will have, let's say
documents that contain,
let's say where cuddly is.
But if let's say you only
used these semantic similarity
search, you would not
have that guarantee.
You would only have documents
that are semantically similar.
And those they
are not guaranteed
to contain keywords
of your prompts.
And so just to illustrate that.
So here, Huggy and Cuddly,
they can be thought
of semantically similar.
So you will probably
not have cuddly--
you will not necessarily
have cuddly in there.
Just to illustrate that.
And that is the reason
why nowadays, what people
do is to look at the use cases
that they have and think about
whether having some heuristic,
as well in the relevance score
is useful for their use case.
So some people, they go
with the hybrid combination
of this embedding-based search
and the heuristic-based search.
So some combination
of embeddings and BM25
in which case you may have.
Even more relevant documents,
depending on your use case.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
So now I'll come back to
what you mentioned about
whether cutting
chunks in a naive way
will necessarily lead you
to things that are coherent.
Well, you're completely right.
Sometimes you will not.
But before we answer
this question,
we actually are going to address
another concern, which is that
typically, when people
want to ask about something
in their LLM, the
query that they input
is of a different
nature compared to what
is in the knowledge base.
So your query is typically
going to be maybe something
short, maybe a question.
But what is in your documents
is typically going to be longer.
These are like
sentences and sentences.
So if you really think about
it, if you use the same encoder
to embed your query and
to embed your documents,
well, these two embeddings,
they're not super comparable,
because one is for a
question and the other one
is for a document.
So there's one extension that
tries to mitigate that issue.
And I link the paper down there.
So it's called the height.
So what it does is instead
of computing the embedding
related to the prompt, it will
first generate a fake document.
So it's just an LLM call, a fake
document based on that prompt.
And then embeds
that fake document
to find relevant chunks.
So it may or may not work.
It's not used all
the time by everyone.
So I would say
just something that
is good to try to
see if that works.
But this is one way
of mitigating this,
another way could be
to simply have encoders
that are specifically trained
to encode the query on one side
and encode the documents
on the other side.
In other words, to not
use the same encoder.
People typically don't
do that, just because
of maintenance purposes.
But this could also
be another solution.
So now, finally going
to your question
regarding how we can make
sense of these chunks.
If they are taken
out of context,
they may not make sense.
And so here, the idea here is to
prepend some piece of text that
just sums up what you need to in
order to understand that chunk.
So here, the idea is that
you have all your documents.
Let's say you have one
document, that you divide it
into n chunks.
The idea here is instead
of considering these chunks
separately, you're going to
compute some kind of context
that is relevant to
each chunk, and that
is based on the whole document.
So how are you going to do that?
Again, the LLM call.
So what you do is
typically, have, let's say,
the whole document.
And then you have the chunk
that you want to contextualize.
And you ask your model,
well, please give me
a short succinct context to
just make sense of that chunk.
And now you may tell me, well,
that's a lot of LLM calls.
You have potentially
a lot of chunks.
And that's just going
to be very pricey.
Well, there's one strategy
to make this less expensive,
and I'm not sure if
you've heard that option.
It's called prompt caching.
So now that you very
well how LLMs work,
you know, typically, these
are decoder only and so on.
So you know that if you
use the same prefix for all
your prompts, well,
it's going to be
the same computations that
you just do again and again
and again.
So the idea here is
you just do it once.
And you save all the
relevant activations.
And instead of
computing them again,
you're just going to look
them up, just do a lookup,
and then decode the rest.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
The question is activation
from a language model.
Yes, because when you feed
a prompt to your model
and you ask it to
generate a response,
what the model needs to do is
well, to take all of this input
and then compute the
activations of all the layers,
and then have for the
generation process
to have this attention across
all these other components.
Well, given that it's
decoder only meaning,
it's only left to right.
The thing that you
input, if it's the same,
then it will lead to
the same activations.
Yeah.
The question is, what if
you have a closed model
where prompt caching,
and I'm going
to just talk about
this in just one slide,
is an option that is closed
models or providers offer?
And what they tell
you is, well, this
is the same prefix
for all your prompts.
So what we're going to
do is we're just going
to make it cheaper for you.
So if you look at the
model pricing page,
you will see that there is
a price for regular inputs.
So inputs that are not cached.
And then you have the price
per cached input token.
And here, you see for the
let's say, OpenAI model,
it's 110th of the price.
So I guess, what do I
want to tell you by this?
Well, just try to be
smart with the prompts
and try to gather
all the things that
are likely to be repeated
across prompts in the beginning.
So that you can leverage
this nice percentage off.
Does that make sense?
OK.
Cool.
Great.
So up until now,
we have seen how
we can go from potentially
thousands or even, let's say,
millions of chunks up to,
or down to, let's say,
hundreds of potentially
relevant chunks.
Now, what we want to
do is to sort them
in a more meaningful way.
And the second part
is more optional,
because maybe sometimes this
first cut that we've done
may be good enough, but I
guess this second step is
about being more
intentional in how
we give the final score to be
able to really select the final,
let's say, top k chunks.
So the second stage is called
ranking or even re-ranking.
Re-ranking because, I
guess, with the first step,
you already have some ranking.
So we're re-ranking.
And what we're doing
is instead of using
this very quick
operation, similarity
operation between embeddings
that we've computed,
we're going to use
something that is maybe
a bit more sophisticated.
So instead of considering
the query and the chunk
separately, what
we're going to do
is to actually put them both
in the encoder, both of them,
and have a relevance
score out of that.
So the reason why it may be a
little bit more meaningful to do
it this way is that
you have a model that
takes a look at both your query
and your chunk at the same time
and gives you a score.
Whereas in the first step,
you had one embedding
for the query and one
embedding for the chunk,
which didn't have that
interaction that a model could
capture.
And you will also see
out there that this setup
is called cross-encoder
setup because you
have both your inputs
fed to your encoder.
So there's some
cross interactions.
So if you remember the first
approach is a bi-encoder setup.
And this one is a cross-encoder.
Yeah.
The question is, you
will actually compute
the attention between the two.
Yes, absolutely.
And here, sentence there they
have a lot of good documents.
So I highly recommend
just reading their docs.
They're at the
bottom of the slide.
Cool.
Well, you do that on all your
potentially relevant chunks.
So you have this
score that is computed
for each of these
chunks with the prompts.
And then you finally
obtain the ranking.
And now the question is, are
you happy with the ranking?
And in order to
answer that question,
you need a way to
quantify your performance.
And that's where we're going to
see in the next five minutes.
What are the metrics that
we typically use to do that?
So again, this is
very similar to if you
do search or recommendation.
So in case you have
a background there,
you will see some commonalities.
So here's the setup.
You have a bunch of chunks.
You do this first
and second step.
And at the end of
the day, you will
have k chunks that
will come at the top,
that you will qualify
as being relevant.
And you want to compare
that with respect
to actually relevant chunks.
So you can think of it as
you have label like, same as
in binary classification.
So you have relevant
and not relevant,
and you predict some
that are relevant
and you want to know
well you're doing.
So this is the setup.
Well, when it comes
to ranking, you
need to somehow incorporate
this information
of how high in the
ranking you've put stuff.
So here, let's
suppose that you have
ranked this n chunks from most
important to least important.
So let's suppose you have
first, second, third, and so on,
and so forth.
And you only care
about the first k,
because in the rack
setting, you typically
retrieve the top k
that are relevant.
And you put all these
top k in your prompt.
Well, the first metric that you
will likely use is called NDCG.
It's a lot of letters.
I'm going to just
explain what that means.
So NDCG tries to quantify
how good your ranking is
by taking into
consideration where
you ranked relevant documents.
So you have this formula
that may seem scary,
but it's actually quite
simple what it's trying to do.
So it's trying to incentivize
the score to be higher.
If your ranking the
relevant documents
closer to the first position.
So what it does, is it is the
sum over the first k positions
that you're ranked.
And it is looking
at whether what
you've ranked for each of these
positions is relevant or not.
So for instance, it
checks the first position.
First position is
irrelevant or not.
So relevance-- if it's
relevant, it's one.
So it's one over some quantity
that is a function of the rank.
And it does that
for all the ranks.
So the score will
be higher if you
rank relevant documents high.
So that's basically the
goal of this metric.
So this part is the
discounted cumulative gain.
So it's cumulative
gain because you're
looking at basically, if
you had relevant documents
in your first k positions,
which is cumulative part,
it's discounted because
it's better for you
to have a relevant
document in position one,
let's say, than position k.
And you can see that
in the denominator.
Now, why do we say NDCG?
What is the normalization part?
Well, this metric can take
a lot of different values,
depending on how many
relevant documents there are.
So what people do is they
compute the quote, unquote,
"ideal or optimal
or upper bound"
DCG that you can get
for a given query,
and they call that ideal DCG,
and they just normalized DCG
over IDCG.
So the reason why
they do that is they
want you to score
a score of one,
if you are matching
the optimal ranking.
They basically want to
make the score meaningful.
So does this make sense?
Yeah?
So the question is, how do they
compute the relevance score?
So you can think
step one and step two
as being a two-step
process for you
to say which documents you
are saying are relevant.
So at the end of
this two-step stage,
the ones that you say
are relevant are here.
Now, you typically have a
score for each retrieved chunk.
So you're going to
sort these chunks.
You're going to sort them by
the score in a descending order.
And the relevance here
that you're going to use
is the actual label.
So is the chunk actually
relevant or not?
So you're going to look at
your k retrieved chunks,
and you're going to
ask yourself, OK,
is the first chunk
actually relevant?
So you have a label.
You know which ones are
relevant, which ones are not.
And these ones are
going to be the ones
you will use in the formula.
Yes, that's the ground truth.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Cool.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
OK.
Great.
So you have a bunch
of other metrics.
You have another one that's
called the reciprocal rank.
So this one is much simpler.
It takes the inverse
of the highest rank
of all the relevant documents.
So if let's suppose in
your top k documents,
let's suppose the first
relevant document, let's say,
comes at rank number two.
Then rank will be equal to two.
So it basically does not care
about any relevant documents
that are past that
first relevant document.
So this is just like
a simpler metric
that typically correlates well.
So that's why people use it.
And then, of course,
you're familiar
with the classic
classification metrics--
recall and precision.
So if you remember, if
you have two classes,
you have the positive class,
you have the negative class.
So recall, what it
does is it takes
a look at all the actually
positive observations,
and it tries to ask itself among
all these actually positive
samples, which are the ones that
you actually predicted positive?
That's the recall
that you all know.
And there is, I guess, a
ranking equivalent, which
is out of all the documents
that are relevant,
actually relevant, so this is
like your positive class, which
are the ones that you actually
predicted as being relevant?
So this is basically which
ones are in the top k?
And similarly, you also have
the precision equivalent.
So if you remember, precision
is out of all the ones
that you have predicted to be
positives, how many of them
are actually positive?
So this is the equivalent here.
So which are the ones that
you've predicted to be positive?
So which are the ones that you
have selected in your top k?
And among those ones, which
ones are actually positive?
So which ones are
actually relevant?
Does that make sense?
So I guess these four metrics--
NDCG, MRR, precision
at k, recall at k,
we see this in a
bunch of papers.
So I just highly
recommend you just
get familiar with their ideas
and maybe with the formula.
And these would be the ones
that you would use to quantify,
whether your retriever is
doing a good job or not.
So you have a bunch of
benchmarks out there.
So there is one that is
actually quite popular.
It's is called massive
text embedding benchmark.
So if you want to
test your retriever,
if it performs well or not would
typically take it, and then
just evaluate it
on that benchmark,
and then have all
these metrics computed.
And then if you have
different solutions,
you would typically
compare this metric.
And with that, we,
I guess, hopefully,
have a better sense of
how to build a RAG system
and specifically how to
have a good retriever.
So we have just maybe
one more minute.
Is there any questions
on that first part?
Yeah?
So the question is,
so for the re-ranking,
we're using an encoder that
will output a relevance score.
So we will typically train
a model that does that.
So there are typically--
I believe there are
some pre-trained ones,
but out there, you can very
well have your custom one.
So that model will typically
be a bit more sophisticated
compared to the first step.
Because here, you can
afford to spend more time
to produce that score because
you're operating out of,
let's say, over 100
possible candidates,
as opposed to let's
say, much more millions
or hundreds of thousands.
So that's the idea.
Yeah?
So the question is, how about
training with contrastive loss?
This is a detail, we
not I guess, cover here.
But in order to
train these models,
you'll have a bunch of different
types of loss function.
So I highly recommend you
read the S-BERT paper,
because in that paper, there
are several loss functions
that the paper tries to compare.
And this is one of them.
So that's a great question.
I highly recommend reading
the S-BERT paper for that.
Cool.
With that, I'll
give it to Shervine.
Thank you, Afshine.
So thanks a lot for covering
the RAG methodology.
So now, we arrive at my
favorite part of the lecture.
We're going to see tool
calling and the agentic world.
And we're going to see
how much more powerful
your LLMs are going to
become just in a second.
So what Afshine
just mentioned is
how you would deal
with incorporating
data that is not structured as
part of your prompts to the LLM.
And now, we're going to
see what we could do more.
In the case, the data that we
want to inject is structured.
So in the case of RAG,
you have documents
with words and words and words.
And you just want to fetch
the relevant documents
to answer your prompts.
But here, let's
suppose that you have
some structure that determines
input/outputs in your data.
So typically, you could
represent it maybe as a table.
So you have separate columns.
And then depending on the
value of given columns,
you have a given output.
So we could probably
reframe that setup
into a function, a setup.
So we mentioned tool calling.
And then this rephrasing is
called the function calling.
So let's suppose that you get
this relationship between input
and output through a function
for the rest of this part.
And then here, if
I had to transpose
what the result of a given ID
and field and other arguments
would look like, you
could interpret it
as a function with
these as arguments.
And the output would be simply
what you have as an output
to the function.
In the world of tool
calling and function
calling, very
oftentimes, you're going
to see that LLMs tend to
use Python as a language,
just because it's
so simple to read.
So this is what we are going
to use as an example as well.
But there is nothing that
ties us to Python necessarily.
So you could well have a tool
calling in other languages.
Just as a note.
Any questions on the setup?
OK.
Awesome.
So there is nothing
controversial about tool
calling, but I'm going to
still state a full definition
to make sure that we
are on the same page.
So I was browsing
here and there,
and I tried to find an
authoritative source.
And this website
like on IBM, there
is an article that defines--
that tries to define
what tool calling is.
So I'm going to anchor on
their definition from now on.
So I'm going to read out loud.
So tool calling allows
autonomous systems
to complete complex tasks
by dynamically accessing
and may act upon
external resources.
So the things that I want you
to get from that are two things.
So first, you have the notion
of completing some task.
So given an input and you have
to complete some task and then
the reliance potentially
on external resources.
So it doesn't have
to be external.
You don't have to rely
on external resources.
But this is one
potential property
that can help you fill the gap
that Afshine was mentioning
at the beginning of the lecture,
regarding filling the knowledge
gap that your
pre-trained LLM has.
So we're going to see
examples in a few minutes,
regarding what that could mean.
But yeah, this is one
magical part of it.
OK.
Great.
And just to make
these statements very
grounded in real-life
applications,
let's just walk through what
would a tool call give us
in the case of a very
specific example?
So let's suppose you
love teddy bears.
You're currently
here at Stanford,
and you want a
teddy bear near you.
What if you pull your
phone out, and you just
ask, find a teddy bear near me.
Well, your current
LLM, without any tools,
would not know some
real-life or like
real-time update of availability
of teddy bears near you.
So it would probably answer
you something in the flavor of,
I don't know or not sure.
And I just want to say
that with the use of tools,
let's see how we
could get to a stage
where we can inject
the information that
is necessary for the LLM to know
how to respond to your query.
And the goal of the
next few minutes
is going to be for
us to figure out,
both what we could do
what-- what we could inject
in the preamble of the LLM?
And what would be the steps that
we could go through in order
to complete such a request?
Does that make sense so far?
Yeah?
So the question is, are those
function APIs pre-computed?
So that's a great question.
So yes, you define
them beforehand.
You have some API.
And we're going to
see that in a second.
They're not LLM
generated on the fly.
OK.
Great.
Any other questions
on the setup?
So I know it will
be a lot to take in.
OK.
Great.
So in order to be
grounded in real life,
let's take a full example of
what a function definition could
be.
So in the case of
finding a teddy bear,
you could imagine a
function definition
that is called find teddy bear.
And depending on your
location, calls some API
and retrieves
potential candidates.
So I'm going to go through the
main characteristics of what
a function call contains and
link it to the definition.
So first of all, when we
want to display such an API
to the model, you
need to document
it, its input and
output, in order
for the model to what
this function is for.
So typically, the
description that you
have in the example of
Python under a given function
would be crucial for the model
to know what it is about.
And then we saw in the
definition of tool call
that we just gave, that
we have the ability
to make backend calls.
And this is exactly
what we would
need to do in the case of
finding teddy bears around you.
You would need to query
some API to retrieve
available teddy bears.
And based on your location,
return the nearest ones.
So this is exactly what
this function implementation
is doing.
It returns something
that is well structured.
So you see maybe it's
small from where you are,
but you have some
class definition that
puts some structure
into the output
and makes it interpretable.
And we're going to see very
soon that this output is going
to be what the model
will anchor on in order
to give its final response.
OK.
Great.
And one other thing I
will say is all of these
that we see here is what
you have implemented.
You will not see all of these--
if you are an LLM, you
will not see all of this.
All you care about as an LLM
is the function API, the input
and output, as well as the
main lines of documentations.
So all these
implementation details,
you're going to have
it on your code base.
But the LLM is not
going to see it.
OK.
Great.
So now, let's go
step-by-step into how
we could make this work.
So the first stage is as
you ask a question that
is related to your
function, you would
insert at the beginning of
your preamble the function API.
And as I mentioned without
its implementation.
So you just have the
function itself, and then
a full documentation.
So here, you would want the
LLM based on your user query
to feed the right
arguments to your function.
s to your point,
the goal of the LLM
here is not going to be to
infer any of the functions
implementations, rather
only what arguments we
should put to it.
Yeah?
So the question is, how
do you even train this?
So we're going to see
that in just a few slides.
Great point.
That's the next question
we need to ask ourselves.
So we're going to see
how we train these.
But here, let's say
it has been trained.
The LLM would have, from
its context, probably
our localization,
because let's say
you have activated your
location permissions
and your LLM knows
where you are.
So it knows you are at Stanford.
And these would
be the coordinates
being fed to your LLM.
And then the second stage is to
actually do that function call.
So it has nothing
to do with LLMs.
You just take your
function, your argument,
and you execute that
and you get some answer.
And the answer, as we
mentioned, is structured
in a way that's understandable.
So in that function
implementation,
you return some object that
informs characteristics
about the return teddy bear.
So for example, you have its
name, maybe location, and so on.
And you feed that
response back to the LLM
in order to get
a final response.
So when you ask to do
LLM a given question,
you don't want to have this
JSON-like response, but rather
a response in natural language.
And this exactly is the
motivation for that last stage.
So I'm going to pause
here for a second
and check that this three-stage
mechanism makes sense
to everyone.
OK.
Great.
And exactly what you
were mentioning here
is going to be the next focus.
How do you even train that?
So let me ask you this question.
If you were to train an
LLM to use this tool,
what steps would you
need to focus on?
So the answer is you're going
to feed the API implementation.
Yes.
So you would need the first LLM
call to be somehow recognizing
the pattern of the function
implementation and the query,
and link it to the
arguments that you
would put in your function.
So yeah.
Great.
So tool prediction.
And do you need a
second set of SFT pairs?
So you have this last stage
that is still LLM-driven,
where you have your tool
answer, and you need
to output a final response.
You might say, OK,
hey, the LLM has
seen a bunch of
structured data and knows
how to put into words,
things that it sees,
which is a fair point.
But usually, you might
want your responses
to be formatted a given way.
So you might want to
also have SFT pairs that
do this mapping the
way you want it to.
So this is why you typically
have these two SFT pairs.
And if I have to be
a bit more precise,
the second pair isn't just
mapping the JSON response
to the final response,
it's actually
linking all the
conversation history so far,
so that it knows that the
initial query was someone
in search of a teddy bear.
It knows there has
been a tool call,
and it knows that the results
correspond to that tool call.
So it would be a slightly
longer input in this SFT pair.
Does that make sense?
OK.
Great.
Yeah?
Yeah.
So great point.
So the question is, what
if we have more tools,
do we need some tool
selection or more examples?
So this is a great topic.
We're going to see it
like in a few slides.
Yeah.
So it's slightly more
complex way of doing things.
But if you want a very quick
answer, if you go the SFT way,
you could show
multi-tool inputs.
So you could include all of
that in your SFT data sets.
But we're going to see the topic
of tool selection very soon.
Great.
Any other questions?
OK.
Awesome.
This is what I just mentioned.
Yeah, the conversation
history so far
is always what you get
as part of the input.
And then the output is what you
would want the LLM to predict
at that given stage.
And since you're
doing SFT here, you
don't have just one, but
multiple such examples.
And you would want your examples
to be varied and representing
the typical user distribution.
So I was asking,
find a bear near me.
And this example
showed to the model
how you could ground the
information of location
based on the user's location,
even though you didn't give it.
And in this other examples,
you could give the model
other kinds of instructions,
directly saying,
I want a bear at that location
to teach the model to look at--
like to ground the argument
at different places.
And you could expand
these sets by also
varying the kind of
input, so it doesn't
have to be worried that way.
You could do it multi-turn maybe
in the middle of a conversation,
you ask for a bear and so on.
OK.
Great.
But this is not the only way
of training a model to do so.
So these days, LLMs become
more and more powerful
in their reasoning.
And the kind of data they
are trained at pre-training
and initial instruction
tuning is typically
these kinds of code data.
So at the end of it, they how
to manipulate Python codes
very well.
So you might ask yourself,
is it really needed for me
to teach the model how to map
a query to a function call?
And that is a very
interesting observation.
And you see these
days that you can
forego of specific SFT training
and try to get around it
with only training.
So here, instead of writing SFT
and then retraining the model,
we're going to see that you
could actually replace it
with only an explanation.
And does anyone have an idea
of how we could even come up
with such an explanation?
So let's say I have a new tool.
I have the API.
I want my model to use it.
How would you go around it?
Yeah, that's a great point.
So one method could
be few shot learning.
You just show in the context
window samples of input/output.
This is a great point.
You could definitely do that.
And this is typically
one accepted practice.
But if I told you
that few shot learning
has challenges when it
comes to generalization,
because you would need to give
specific points as input/output.
So it might fit to
some cases and not
necessarily
unnecessarily generalized
to the whole span
of human language.
Is there another way
you could go around it?
Yeah.
So the answer is ask
it to do reasoning.
Great point.
And writing a prompt that does
the reasoning in a way that
makes sense is very hard.
So in practice, you
wouldn't write it yourself.
You would take these SFT pairs.
So these are the behavior
that you want to enforce.
And you could use it
as some evaluation set.
So you could say, OK, hey,
if I ask this question,
I want that stool call.
And you have a set of pairs.
And you could run
whatever you have
so far in terms of explanation.
You evaluate these prompts
against the evaluation set.
So you have some
wins and losses.
Maybe find a bear in Paris.
Doesn't work well.
Some other prompts do.
So you have a list of
each sample with a score.
And you could feed it
back to a reasoning model,
typically, to do the
explanation writing for you.
So this is a trick to help you
avoid doing that hard work.
Basically, showing the model,
hey, with the current prompts,
here's what we get.
What would you have changed in
order to make the evaluation
results better?
So you get with that
process an iteration
on the detailed explanation.
And if you have to see
results in practice,
you would be surprised
at how well it
does the explanation for you.
So the takeaway here
is I do not recommend
you write it end-to-end.
Maybe just a draft and you
let some very powerful model
with excellent knowledge
of logic do it for you.
Yeah?
Yeah.
So the question is,
what you just mentioned,
is it training or inference?
So it's training.
So you do it at
the very beginning.
You want a fixed prompt
that explains to the LLM
how to use it, how
to use that function.
So you would typically
do that offline.
Offline you iterate
on the explanation
that says exactly how
you use the prompt, how
you use the function.
And then at inference time, you
would put that fixed explanation
alongside the function API,
such that for any query,
it knows what to do.
Does that make sense?
OK.
Great.
Any other questions here?
OK.
Amazing.
I just mentioned an
example with teddy bears
that would be in the category
of maybe informational.
So you have a question and you
want to ask some external API
to retrieve that.
And you have in reality
a lot more use cases
that you might see.
So one actually mentioned,
you have some cutoff dates.
And let's say you ask your
LLM about news of the day.
So you typically wouldn't
have anything that
comes from the model itself.
You would have an API that
fetches it from a tool called
maybe Search.
But you have also
other kinds of tools
available in the
information category.
So for example,
whether stocks and,
let's see, but you also
have other categories.
For example, if you
want to ask the model to
do some calculation for you.
You could let the
model figure it out
with some reasoning chain.
But one way to get around
it is to transform the query
into code, execute that code,
and then read out the answer.
So this is why tool call has
a whole span of applications
in the computation area.
So you have calculations.
And you have another category
that we can cite here.
So you can take actions
on behalf of the user.
So let's say you have a
tool that sends emails.
You could ask the model
to send an email for you,
and it could put
the right things
into the header and the message
body, and even hit Send for you
because you have
that component that
interacts with the external
world as part of the tool API.
Yeah.
So these are just
a few examples,
but I just want to say that
the field of tool calling
is so powerful.
You can do anything you want.
And in practice, exactly
as you mentioned,
you wouldn't have just a single
tool API as part of the context.
You would have several ones
because your LLM is not just
an LLM for finding bears.
You might want to do other
things with your LLM.
Maybe you want to
hug a teddy bear
or check a teddy bear's
moods, send teddy bear's
a gift and other things.
So you have a lot
more functions that
might be relevant to
be added as a preamble.
Just because you don't know what
function would need to be used,
you just need to put all
of that just in case.
The setup is exactly
the one that you
mentioned where you don't have
just one API but multiple ones.
Does anyone see any
issues with doing so?
So the suggestion is that,
that's a lot of tools.
And then you're right.
So typically, if you
have too many tools,
you have the problem
that Afshine mentioned
at the beginning of a
needle in a haystack,
where maybe some tool API
will get lost in the context
and you don't
really what to use.
You have a lot of
conflicting APIs, maybe,
and we're going to see very
soon how to overcome that issue.
OK.
Great.
So I want to take a pause here
and summarize how far we've come
and some of the
drawbacks that we have
and see together what we could
do to remedy these drawbacks.
So first, we saw that
we came from an LLM that
just responded back at
you with a normal words.
To an LLM that can actually
interact with the outside world,
fetch real-time
information, or even extends
computing capabilities.
And exactly like
overcomes the issue
that Afshine was mentioning
the knowledge cutoff
one in a different way that
than what RAG would do.
So you could see these two
methods as being complementary.
And yeah, both try to do the
same thing in some sense.
But exactly as someone mentioned
here, if you have more tools,
then your context
window might have things
that it doesn't need.
And then if you try to
support so many cases,
you might end up being
mediocre at all of them.
So this is an issue.
And even if that
wasn't an issue,
you still have the context
window that is finite.
So let's say you have
hundreds of millions
of users that use
your LLM and that want
to use to do a lot of things.
You cannot support
everyone's use cases at once,
just because you couldn't
possibly fit all of such tools
in your context.
And then last, when I
mentioned these tools,
these are things I hand wrote.
And maybe each LLM has their own
way of defining and using tools.
We're going to see if there
is a way to standardize,
maybe the way we define
and use tools later on.
So do these
drawbacks make sense.
Yeah.
OK.
Great.
So let's move on
to tool selection.
So let's see what
we could do in order
to make a tool
use more scalable.
So I'm going to cite
here a technical paper
from Google DeepMind, which
uses a tool selector system.
So it functions in two steps.
So first you have
your query and you
have a list of tools that
can be as big as you want.
And a list of
tools only contains
the API name and, maybe one or
two words about what it does.
So you have this prompt
and the list of tools.
And we ask the LLM to pick the
tools that might be relevant.
So this is why the technical
paper calls this system tool
selector.
You could even see
the term router being
pronounced in the literature.
So tool selection, routing
are similar concepts.
And the goal here is to
restrict the number of tools
to only those that
might be useful.
And in the second stage, you
take all the selected tool APIs
and feed only those to the
context alongside your query.
And this is one
way you could take
to overcome this issue of
having too many tools at once.
Is everyone convinced that tool
selection could be a good way
to fix the problem here?
So the question is
that basically RAG?
You could do it with RAG.
That's a great point.
But it doesn't
necessarily have to.
So you could have an LLM
that does this job, just
picking the right tools.
And you ask some
instructions to the LLM
to output the right answer.
You could definitely
do it with RAG.
That is just a great point.
Yeah.
So does it make
sense to everyone?
OK.
Great.
And I see time is flying.
So we're going to go very
quickly on the standardization
issue.
So as I mentioned, every
tools implementation,
like the way you specify
a tool implementation
can be bespoke to a given LLM.
And you wouldn't want that.
Because for every
LLM, you might need
to implement always these
tools over and over again.
And duplication is
not what you want.
This is why there is
a standard called MCP,
that I know a lot of
people talk about it.
So it's something from
the Anthropic team
that standardizes the way
tools are exposed to models.
So it's a protocol.
It's called a model
context protocol.
And it defines a standard way
of presenting these tools.
So I'm going just to say
the very big lines of it,
so you have this kind of
vocabulary as part of MCP.
So you have an MCP
server, which is
the instance that serves tools.
And then tools are
implementations of the functions
that you want people to use.
Prompts are templates that
could show the user how
to use these tools.
And then all of these
can anchor on resources,
which are external
databases that you
can use to complete the task.
And then an MCP server,
when you use it,
has a one-to-one
connection with a piece
of infrastructure in your LLM
host that is called MCP clients.
But these are maybe
infrastructure details.
And I just want to ground what
I just mentioned in reality.
So we know our teddy bear
loves to read poetry.
So in the case of recommending
a poetry book to our teddy bear,
you could think of a
MCP server that provides
tools that are linked to books.
So your LLM hosts here--
so let's just take
the example of Claude
since MCP is from Anthropic.
So Claude would
be your LLM host.
Your MCP server would
be probably implemented
by your book provider.
Because typically, they
are the most experts
as at serving such content.
And we could assume that
the book provider, MCP
server has tools regarding
finding books or recommending
them.
And then the prompts here
could be a ways to show you
how to find a given
title, or maybe
recommend it with respect to
some flavor, maybe with respect
to the user's test taste.
And some examples
of resources here
could be the teddy bear's
personal collection,
or maybe top books that people
buy, just as an example.
OK.
Awesome.
So now, I'm going to
come to potentially
the most exciting part
of today's lecture,
which is agents.
So we saw how much more powerful
LLMs could become with tools.
Agents could be seen as
one layer up from it.
So I'm going to give
first a definition,
just so that we agree of
what agent means here.
So it's a system that
autonomously pursues
goal and completes tasks
on a user's behalf.
So compared to tools, you
not only can perform tasks,
but you have also some
reasoning involved in it.
So you could have multiple
loops of iterations.
And this is what
differentiates an agent
from a tool in plain terms.
When usually people
talk about agents,
it has that recurrence or
higher level of reasoning baked
into it.
And so I'm going to contrast
like the agentic world
with respect to
the world we have
seen, where you may have
multiple calls to tools.
And these new agentic
framework is not
necessarily disjoint from the
ones that we presented before.
You could well have reasoning
chains inside of it.
So it's like a
potentially overlapping.
But the structure consists
of tool calls and iterations.
OK.
Great.
And now, I'm going to talk about
a hallmark paper called ReAct,
to reason plus acts, which
decomposes possible loops
into different stages.
So very oftentimes, when you
have a query and you want
to pursue a goal, you
cannot do it one shot.
You need somehow to
decompose the goal
into actionable substeps,
perform each of these steps,
and then come up
with the answer.
And this is exactly
what ReAct is about.
It's about decomposing complex
tasks into loops of things
that can be done atomically.
So here, I just want
to say one thing.
We decompose these steps
into observe, plan, and act.
But it doesn't necessarily
have to be called that way
or be in that order.
For example, the
ReAct paper, I think,
introduces terms
think, observe, act.
You might see the language
changing a bit from paper
to paper to paper.
But the high-level
intuition remains.
So let's just ground on
a very specific example.
So to be in the theme
of these days weather,
it starts becoming a bit cold.
And our teddy bear might
be cold in its home.
So let's just have
that as an input.
My teddy bear is cold.
Please, do something.
And let's see what an agentic
workflow could do about it.
So first, you have
this observe stage,
which translates the user query
into an actionable formulation.
So when you say that
your teddy bear is cold
and you ask it to do
something like here,
in this observe stage,
you would link it back
to the notion of temperature.
The user's teddy
bear is cold, which
may be due to the current
temperature of the room, which
is currently unknown.
So right off the
bat, you now know
that you need to do
something with temperatures.
So this brings us
to the next step
called Plan, where that
something is unknown,
and you need to find it.
Plan will spell
that out for you.
So here, you want to determine
the temperature of the room.
And luckily, among
your tools, you
might have something that
does something in these lines.
And this is where you use it.
So the Act stage is
using all these APIs
that might be in the context.
So for example here, if you have
get current room temperature,
this is the way to use it.
And as I mentioned, these
tools are useful to the LLM
when you output information back
to it that it can interpret.
So this tool returns
the temperature.
And you need now to interpret
what the temperature means.
So this is why you go back
to the observed stage.
You describe what
the world looks like
and what you should do about it.
So here, you can read that the
temperature of the room is cold.
It's 65 Fahrenheit,
and the observed stage
might indicate that it's
colder than expected.
So this is why you
need to plan something.
And then at the Plan
stage, you're like this,
this was colder than expected.
So I need to increase
the temperature.
And then you go back
to the Act stage.
Luckily, how to increase
the temperature.
And it has a function that can
have the temperature increase
arguments and put it to it, so
you can adjust the temperature.
And then once it's
done, the observed stage
concludes that the
temperature is not
set to the correct temperature.
And this is the time where
you can exit the loop
and return the
response to the user.
So here, we have increased
the temperature by 5 degrees.
And then the output reads that
back to the user in the hope
that it has fulfilled
the user's query.
So what I described
within the loop
is what makes a
workflow an agentic one.
So you have some initial query.
You have some actions
that you can perform.
And then at each
stage, the LLM tries
to see if it has
reached the goal yet.
And then if it has, then it
will go to the output stage.
Otherwise, it may have
more reasoning loops,
where it does more work.
So does the definition of agent
that I propose here make sense?
OK.
Great.
So now taking this
a bit further,
you could think of way
more than one agent.
You could have an agent
for setting the thermostat.
But maybe in your home,
you want to manage
how energy is distributed,
or air quality,
if you have some
settings to tune.
So you can have
different agents.
And one interesting use case is
to have the user say something
to an agent, and
potentially have all of them
communicate together.
So these prompts potential
needs for also a standardization
of communications
between agents,
similarly to what we have seen
between LLM hosts and tools.
And this is what prompted
Google to release
the Agent2Agent protocol
earlier this year.
So yeah, highly recommend
taking a look at their document
specification.
But just to give the
main lines around it,
you have some standardization
of what an agent can expose.
So it typically exposes
a set of skills.
So it can do things.
And then it gives
examples about it
so that other agents
are aware of it.
And what you need
to do as a developer
would be to define these skills.
And also, another key thing is
to define how the agent executes
a given request.
So for example, when you
execute a given query,
what is the status that
you emit to other agents?
Or there is a cancel
method, as well,
where let's say an agent
says, stop what you're doing.
What is the process
to cancel an action?
So these are some of
the main functions
like the Agent2Agent protocol
asks people to fill out.
Yeah?
So the question is, is each
agent an LLM with some context
to do some tasks?
So you could definitely
imagine it be the case.
Typically, in the example
that I mentioned here, yes.
And the agents
operate independently.
So they have their
own reasoning loops.
And all the other agency
is the input and output.
Yeah.
So the remark here is
maybe your token budget
can go all over the place.
So you can have some budget
restrictions put in place.
This is a good point.
But each of these
agents, they would not
eat on each other's budgets.
It might eat on
your money budget,
but this is indeed a concern.
So I'm going to move on to
the topic of safety, which
I have not mentioned so far.
But that is very
important because with
these new capabilities
comes a whole string
of new potential issues.
And you have seen these models.
They have now the ability
to execute actions for you.
So you could think of some
harmful actor doing things
that you wouldn't want for you.
And I give one example here
that could be a concern--
data exfiltration.
So let's say you have access
to a tool that can write
in a public visible way data.
So let's say you have, I
don't know some email agent.
So if you have a prompt that,
for example, says, write
my password, which potentially
the tool could have access
to to an email to
that address, you
could exfiltrate data that
belongs to the user out of it.
So this is typically one
risk that you might have.
You can have other safety risks.
And I link the paper here that
goes through some of them.
So tool sort.
So I recommend a read.
Now, you might ask, what
could you do to get around it?
So you have typically two
classes of remediations.
One that might come
at the training
stage where, if you recall
the training process of R1
or even other models, you have
these harmlessness components.
So you typically have data
as part of the data mixtures
that you train during SFT and
reinforcement learning that
could cover safety.
So this is where you
could remedy these issues.
You have another option.
Let's say, you have
a query that has
gone through your lines
of defenses, your training
lines of defenses.
You can also have
inference safeguards.
For example, safety classifier
that looks at the conversation
so far, and that judges
whether the output of the LLM
is going to be safe or not.
So you have even
that as a safeguard.
And just as a pointer, I'm going
to talk about that agent safety
bench, which summarizes the
span of possible safety hazards
and offers a benchmark,
a full suite for it.
So people can refer
to these benchmarks
to know whether
their LLM is safe.
And it's a very important topic.
And just yesterday,
Anthropic revealed
that there were the victims
of a large scale cyber
attack launched from Claude.
So this is an issue that is--
so it was also using tools
and agentic capabilities,
and they published
super detailed report,
saying exactly what
the attackers did
and went step-by-step through
possible lines of remediations.
And this is just to emphasize
how important safety
is in this more capable world.
And both attackers and
the line of defense
can be more and
more sophisticated.
So it's not a lost battle, it's
just that the tools we have
for defending against like
tool-based attacks need to be--
so we need to have
such measures in place.
And with these measures,
maybe it's going to be fine.
So I think that was the overall
mindset of that article, which
I strongly recommend to read.
I'm going to say
a last few words.
So when you talk
about agents, you
have this risk that at every
step of your thought process,
you might diverge to something
that just doesn't work.
So that is a huge problem.
Let's say if the model doesn't
grounds to the output properly,
or maybe does a mistake into the
argument prediction of a tool
call, so this is
one big issue, which
is the reason why you don't
see large scale agents ruling
the world right now, because
it's really like, we are limited
by these consequences.
And then I'm going to
talk about the developing
capabilities of models
that enable you to have
this agentic capabilities.
So this is something that
you can fix with SFT.
But ideally, you wouldn't want
to use SFT to fix reasoning gaps
and use the model itself.
And we're going to see next
week what the evaluation
landscape looks like.
So I'm going to reserve
it to next week.
And just a few words of advice
regarding building tools
or building agents, always start
small on a very simple case.
For example, find
the nearest bear.
Try to see if your current
implementation and prompts just
works and then start from there.
So start small and
then start smart.
So take the most
capable model first so
that you know the
headroom of where
you can go with
the current models,
and then try to gain on
latency capabilities and so on.
Start correct, start small, and
then you can optimize later.
And when it comes
to debuggability,
these LLMs they output
chains of reasoning.
So it's always good
to look at them,
to see what is going wrong.
And I will close this
lecture on a note.
My favorite use case of
using agents right now
is as an AI assistant coding.
So this is something I
strongly recommend in case
you have a project
that requires you
to do complex piping of things.
You can free your mental load by
delegating some of these tasks.
And this is something
that is you're
going to see in the real
world, very much used now,
but with the caveat
that, please make
sure to learn the
foundations of codes,
know how to code right,
because your taste is going
to matter most from now on.
Generating code is
cheap, but judging
whether a code is correct,
and does the right thing,
this is the hard part.
And with that, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]